[Applause]
[Music]
we told you in a previous video how
Saudi Arabia wants to leave behind once
and for all its addiction to oil and
become a nation similar to dubai or abu
dhabi in this video we're going to look
at the country in more depth in order to
get an idea of just how this mission to
get free from oil is going the thing is
there is a specific name a leader behind
this ambitious plan and my question to
you is do you know who this person is
well for those of you don't the person
who is turning everything upside down in
Saudi Arabia is Mohammed bin Salman but
my name alone it doesn't explain much so
now you might be wondering who is this
man really what are his intentions and
what exactly is he trying to do well
these are the questions that we're going
to the answering in today's visual
politic video so let's get started shall
we
a prince of change might only be a
little more than 30 years old but
Mohammed bin Salman is already one of
the most powerful people in the world
and he controls more money than we could
ever possibly count formerly well he is
the Minister of Defence deputy Crown
Prince second deputy prime minister
chief of the Royal quarter hands chair
of the Council for economic and
development affairs so what does all of
this mean well it kind of means the
Bahamas bin Salman is in control of
wealth everything he's got complete
control over the country's oil over the
massive financial reserves that have
been accumulated over the years and also
over Saudi Arabia's massive defense
budget so today the power of the prince
is practically total and say well this
isn't something normal either never have
such a young man had so much power
before up until now the norm was for the
country to be controlled by seniors of
80 or more years who were very reluctant
to go for any kind of change but all of
a sudden changes on the first because
what Mohammed bin Salman is trying to do
with Saudi Arabia is turn it into a new
United Arab Emirates a country which the
prince has an enormous amount of
admiration for later we're going to see
just how he is doing this but for now
you need to bear something in mind the
use of the country cheer bin Salman as
the savior of the kingdom and this is a
country where half of its population is
less than 25 years old and so in a
country like that it's pretty important
but then anyway be wondering why does
this man come from how can such a young
man have so much power well he's the son
of the
current king last way just a second
before you explain well of course he is
because you need to know that being the
son of the king in Saudi Arabia wasn't
always such an important thing in fact
for now then samal is not even the heir
to the Saudi throne the battle over the
throne Salman bin Abdulaziz is the king
of Saudi Arabia he is the son of the man
who is considered the founder of the
country Abdul Aziz bin Saud well since
Sal died in 1953 the kingdom has been
inherited by brother dr. brother dual
Aziz bin Saud had seventeen known wives
and it is calculated that he also had
around thirty two sons so there were
quite a few potential heirs the thing is
but when the current king here is
believed to be the 25th son reached
power a few years ago in 2015 the first
thing he did was change the laws of
succession even though some of his
brothers are still alive he has decided
to put the new generations in charge of
this process to do this he has decided
to appoint his nephew Muhammad bin Nayef
who is closer to Washington than others
and he has been in charge of security
for the last few years as well as Secret
Service's and the fight against
fundamentalism
however it seems like young Mohammed bin
Salman the main character in this video
it seems he's not very happy about that
and it seems that he is taking aim at
the throne he wants to be the future
king of Saudi Arabia so his eagerness
for reforms could be explained as an
attempt to gain popularity in fact that
is what most analysts currently think
that means well it does make sense the
fall of the price of oil has given
Mohammed bin Salman the opportunity to
aim for the throne which is something
needs father obviously support if sound
vision 2030 starts showing good result
in Salman will be in a better position
to ask for a reward and become
potentially the new heir to the throne
however there are a few problems on the
road ahead though for then some are as
well as the country on the one hand
there are problems inside the royal
family bin Salman has made a lot of
enemies who accuse him of being
power-hungry
on the other hand his father the current
king is quite old 81 years and he seems
to have some memory issues
so this means that there are two
possible scenarios ahead if the current
king lives for many more years the
prince in someone will be able to
consolidate his power however if the
King doesn't live so long the current
head in someone's cousin could become
the new king and wish goodbye both to
the prince and his saudi vision 2013 as
the reality is is that this is how
monarchies work but I'm pretty sure that
some of you by now are probably thinking
well this is all fascinating Simon that
why should I care what happens in Saudi
Arabia well you should care and probably
more than you think
Saudi Arabia is still the biggest oil
producer and it is also the most
important and influential country in the
Arab world
[Music]
and through the Lucian towards openness
for this country could be something very
positive for the world can spinel the
planned salary vision 2030 it seems to
be the only opportunity for the country
to progress and the involved but now
that we've said that what exactly is the
plan for this country incorrigibles
so far in today's story we've seen a
handsome prince and they battle over the
throne but we need a third ingredient
for this Saudi soap opera and that's
luxury and money well of all the royal
families in the world the South the
royal household of Saudi Arabia might be
the most addicted to money and luxury
and well now you're going to see why as
we have mentioned in several videos the
full of oil prices has jeopardized many
countries and among them is Saudi Arabia
only in 2016 and even though many
adjustments were made the country had a
deficit of more than eighty billion
dollars and now the question becomes
what can we do in order to fix such a
hole in their budget well in 2016 the
Saudi government announced that the
country was going to go on a diet sowing
for the first time in decades
austerity reached Saudi Arabia the
government of bin Salman started with
reductions in public wages canceled many
projects whose profitability was
uncertain reduced subsidies and gasoline
water electricity
yeah
this was a pretty huge shock all of the
most subsidised economies in the world I
mean up until now their view oil it
helps pay for everything in Saudi Arabia
however hold on for just a moment
because well that's not the whole story
under Solomon's rule princes still enjoy
many material privileges the
subsidization system hasn't changed for
the royal household take a look at this
the king of Saudi Arabia has ultra
luxurious palaces all over the world
that are available to him in Marbella in
Spain he has el rocío a palace inspired
by no less than the White House
[Music]
but I mean it's got to be pretty boring
right have to go to the same Palace all
the time I mean how tiresome so lost
some of the King built a new and
gigantic Palace in Tangier in Morocco
the palace has it's very own hospital
and here the King gets French seafood
delivered direct from France but I mean
hey what's the problem with chartering a
few airplanes so the king can eat some
nice lobsters right oh and by the way
when the king of Saudi Arabia travels
they traveled big in his last tour
around Asia in 2016 the king traveled
with 1,500 people and he took within two
mercedes-benz s 600 limousines
in order to carry it all 27 planes had
to be used yes so it seems that this is
what the royal family considers
austerity and the prince our main
character he's no different either
during holidays in France and at the
same time oil prices were following
Prince Salman saw the yacht of the
Russian magnate Yuri schaeffler it was
love at first sight he sent an assistant
right away in order to close the deal
Salman bought it for 550 million US
dollars so now you know how the family
likes to live and well they are quite a
big family so estimations indicate that
the Saudi royal family has around 15,000
members the government has evaded the
question of membership numbers but even
low-end estimates put it at about 5,000
people and we're talking about people
who live thanks to the public budget and
have all kinds of privileges they are
paid impressive salaries they have
access to hospitals which are
essentially five-star palaces and they
do profitable business with the
government they have incredibly
luxurious
spends honestly rather incredible
lifestyles and the reality is that that
is very very expensive
according to estimations from the US
government since transparency is not a
tradition in the royal family as they
spend about two billion dollars every
year in order to keep up their sumptuous
lifestyle but some other estimates
indicate the royal family takes over a
million barrels of oil a day which is
10% of the national production the
progress of Saudi vision 2030
to find all of this the transition of
Saudi Arabia planned in vision 2030
keeps moving forward
Saudi Arabia designs a city of
entertainment almost as big as Las Vegas
lots of the truth is that it is moving
slowly and for the time being Saudi
Arabia is regaining better relations
with the United States in fact Donald
Trump's first international visit as the
US president was to react but yes in
order to achieve that or the Saudis had
to sign some pretty big checks Trump
signs the single largest arms deal in US
history with Saudi Arabia were three
hundred and fifty billion dollars and
this has to be added to the billion
dollar contracts they already have with
some of the largest companies in the
United States and it all has a target in
mind
Saudi Arabia wants to reinforce the
protection it has from the u.s. to
defend for impossible enemies such as
Iran where are you going to be
discussing the special relationship in a
future video so please do not forget to
subscribe but leaving the u.s. aside in
the last few months Saudi Arabia has set
the world's largest fund for
technological investments they have 100
billion dollars available to invest
furthermore the country is eliminating
many restrictions on foreign investments
and some projects are being already
discussed some of these have already
been put into motion such as theme park
huge hotel resorts and even nuclear
power plants but as we have been telling
you transforming this country won't be
easy at all and this is just the start
of their very own soap opera there's a
huge money wastage of the royal family
which means there to deal with a lot of
criticism from the country's powerful
religious leaders who by the way have a
terrible lack of respect for civil
rights then there is the war in Yemen
and the uncertainty of the heir to the
Saudi throne so now what do you think
about the luxurious lifestyle of the
Saudi royal family do you think Riyadh
will ever become some sort of Dubai well
please leave your answers in the
comments below and do you click like if
you enjoyed this video and don't forget
to subscribe for brand new videos just
like this every Monday and every
Thursday and as always I'll see you in
the next video and if you want to learn
more about politics and hear even more
of my lovely voice you can join us at
reconsider media we have a podcast at
reconsider mediacom slash podcast see
you there
[Music]
you